oh my gosh this whole time i was
chatting with everyone i was saying tim
thank you
so thank you thank you tim
it's a great thing that i'm testing out
this live streaming
jeez okay i can only be here for about
10 minutes or so
i have to get going shortly this is
primarily for me to test this out
okay there we go all right
i kept saying thank you thank you tim
thank you tim carr thank you tim trainer
and
yes yes and so on i forgot what i had
said
okay working sounds good thank you thank
you
jake not from state farm where'd you get
your name from
how'd you come up with that
[Music]
hey
ah right right jake jake from state farm
okay okay
i forgot the person's name who said
they're from state from state farm
so where are you all joining in from
what part of the world
hi laura thank you so much laura for
moderating i appreciate that thank you
hi from toronto to denmark
oregon hi
germany hi north carolina hi the
netherlands wow texas
i assume that many of you are here from
the jordan peterson interview that just
occurred so what was something that was
insightful what was
a point that sticks out or that stuck
out to you
hey jake from michigan
i was incredibly nervous during that
interview incredibly incredibly
i couldn't even look at peterson i
couldn't look at anyone in the eye so i
had a screen on a screen with some text
here for some aliens
soon well i can't
well okay
i hope you're not disappointed
thank you tim
m as in michigan
u of m
they have a uap course
hey how's it going
hey cmac
i'm testing all of this out
we'll get going in about
three
three minutes or so
i need to look into his theories
jake
thank you so much see mac i appreciate
it
laura what's the course about
are you able to place it in the
description or will youtube censor it
scanning the skies
interesting
interesting interesting
okay this is not the university of
michigan is it it says michigan online
is that the same
is that an offshoot
yes it says it's powered or copyrighted
by
university of michigan
well that's extremely interesting
laura if you're able if you know the
coordinator of this can you please email
me their name or their email address
how's my day been it's been it's been
not bad so far
got
a moderate amount of work done and then
i have some meetings to attend to
shortly
james i need to look into that
how's your day been
asgard
okay
okay well i gotta get going so it was
nice seeing everyone
again this is just a test so i apologize
if it's uninteresting
i plan on doing these more hopefully
they'll have a
point to them so i mentioned before
maybe what i'll do
is i'll study
while i live stream and then i'll
occasionally check the chat and then
maybe i'll share my screen
for people to see what i'm looking at if
they're interested in that or i'll
invite other podcasters on because many
people say i should talk to so-and-so
podcaster but i'm not terribly
interested in speaking with podcasters
on toe i'm interested in speaking with
other people who
who don't have a not to say that they
don't have a voice but that they don't
have their own podcast
or that they have
interesting points of view that i feel
like i can tease out that they haven't
teased out elsewhere
but for something like this
i see no reason why i can't say hey why
don't we just
speak for a few moments on
youtube live
even if there's 20 people watching
james thank you nice to see you all
and
take care
yes it's like youtube and chill
so
you